صاحب السمو الملكي أمير
ويلز الكومنولث ، وهي جمعية من
الدول المستقلة التي نشأت من
رماد الإمبراطورية البريطانية ،
سيخلف الأمير تشارلز والدته
الملكة في
الوقت الذي يقول فيه لمواجهة الماضي ،
أريد أن أعترف بأن
جذورنا  إن الارتباط المعاصر
يمتد إلى أعماق الفترة الأكثر إيلامًا في
تاريخنا ،
ولا يمكنني وصف
أعماق حزني الشخصي
لمعاناة الكثيرين
حيث أواصل تعميق
فهمي الخاص لتأثير العبودية الدائم ،
ويرحب المندوبون من المستعمرات البريطانية السابقة مثل سيراليون
الملاحظات ربما كانت حالة تأخر أفضل
من
عدم العبودية جزءًا من
المحادثة ، لذا فإن حقيقة أننا
كنا مسؤولين اليوم نتحدث عن
العبودية ونرى كيف نريد أن نبدأ
تلك المحادثة الصمت
يتطلع إلى ذلك ونأمل أن  عندما
يبدأ ، سوف يقوم بزيارة إلى أستراليا
ويذهب ويرى بعض السماء
التي تركتها العبودية بالكامل
15 دولة لا تزال تحتفظ بالملكة ، حيث قام
رئيس الدولة بربادوس بإزالتها
في العام الماضي فقط ، وكان الأمير تشارلز هناك
لتسليم السلطة إلى رئيس معين حديثًا
، تضم دول الكومنولث
بداخلها
دولًا
كانت لها علاقات دستورية
مع عائلتي ،
وبعضها لا يزال يفعل ذلك
و  وأريد أن أقول بشكل متزايد أولئك
الذين لم يكن لديهم
أي إمبراطورية ، كما قلت من
قبل ،
إن الترتيب الدستوري لكل عضو
كجمهورية أو ملكية
هو مجرد مسألة تخص كل
دولة عضو أن تقرر
عدم وجود إمبراطورية بريطانية بعد الآن ،
لكن الندوب التي خلفتها وراءها ما زالت
تلتئم  الأمير تشارلز يريد التحدث
عن ذلك ويريد
أن يكون الكومنولث هو المنصة
ماكس فوستر سي إن إن كيغالي رواندا